So there was a social media summit at the
White House last week and over the weekend
I got so many messes.
So
just from people saying, David, you've got
to talk about it.
Your boy Tim pool was there a, it was really
this hilarious comedy of errors.
It was punctuated most hysterically actually
by Twitter, not only not being invited to
the social media summit, but Twitter's platform
actually went down during the summit and became
inaccessible so nobody could tweet about what
was going on as it was happening for a whole
bunch of the time because Twitter was down.
I mean, it's seriously the stuff of legend.
But let's actually break through.
Let's bring it down piece by piece a little
bit.
So first of all, the entire premise of the
summit was that Donald Trump believes that
conservative voices are being targeted and
silenced by social media.
It's not just Donald Trump who believes this.
There's a huge contingent, uh, of the right
that believes that conservative voices are
being targeted and silenced by Twitter, by
Youtube, by Facebook.
They're all left wing as far as this conspiracy
theory goes.
And Donald Trump reportedly told the room
of people, um, such innovative and amazing
insights as quote, some of you are extraordinary.
The crap you think of is unbelievable.
And yet Facebook wasn't invited.
Google wasn't invited, Twitter wasn't invited,
but Donald Trump did say during the summit
that he would soon invite them and that he
would scold them in person for the liberal
bias that Donald Trump believes that they
exhibit.
So many of the complaints from the right are
about the moderation of content.
Uh, but of course the attendees to the summit
itself were required to submit their questions
in advance of the social media summit if they
wanted to say anything.
Independent journalists, Tim Poole, who I've
interviewed and no personally, it was one
of the invitees and he posted some hilarious
stuff from it, including these oversized boards
with definitions for words like shadow banning,
doxing, d platforming, and demonetization,
which the sign for demonetization describes
is preventing people from earning money for
their content based on political viewpoints
of platforms, which of course we have widely
debunked the youtube demonetization that's
going on and that is affecting us.
And the deep prioritization of our content
on, I have not seen any evidence that it's
politically biased.
And what if I thought even remotely that that
was the case.
I would be saying youtube is deprioritizing
and demonetizing left-wing content like mine,
but that would be dishonest.
I don't believe that that's the case.
I don't believe that what's going on is politically
biased.
It appears to be biased against independent
creators and towards legacy establishment,
corporate creators on the basis of just being
safe for big brands to advertise on.
So we've talked about that already.
That's another joke.
But then the funniest part again was Twitter
being down globally for about an hour during
the event.
So there's some farcical elements here.
Uh, there's the entire premise of the event
being conservatives are being widely censored
online, and there's obvious political bias
against conservatives and towards progressive's
online, which is a joke.
We are a great example of the reality that
that's not the case.
We've talked about this many times before.
As I've said previously, just because a company
has sort of a center left culture or says,
Hey, you've got to use the gender pronouns
that people want to be called by at work.
That doesn't mean that the companies are inherently
left wing in terms of their place in the corporate
status quo.
This would be like saying that in 1962 a company
that had a policy that said, we don't allow
calling black people the n word.
Oh, that's a liberally biased company.
It's ridiculous.
Okay.
Number two, the people selected for this social
media summit make the event truly laughable.
I mean, look at the list.
There was a conspiracy theorist named Bill
Mitchell who promoted Q and on conspiracy
theories online that was invited to the White
House.
Some guy behind a pro Trump meme account on
Twitter that does nothing of actual journalistic
or sociopolitical or cultural commentary value.
Brett Bozell who was one of the most storied
right wing ideologues who once compared Barack
Obama to a skinny ghetto crackhead.
He was invited as some kind of media critic
project Veritas, which completely flopped
with a bogus so-called investigation into
planned parenthood selling baby parts was
involved, invited and then a smattering of
more established right wing groups.
I'm not mentioning everyone, but I think you
sort of get the gist of it, so to say.
You want to figure out social media and then
you invite arranged, have basically whacked
out conservatives to centrists.
It's terrible.
I told Tim Pool, we were chatting before the
event and I said, Tim, it would be really
great if you showed up and you said to Trump,
hey, we really should have had progressive's
here.
If you can, even by the way, get yourself
on video mentioning you should have had David
Pakman here.
We would obviously play that on the show.
That's just my personal bias, but in any case,
say something about the total lack of political
diversity here other than going basically
from the center to the extreme.
I don't believe that that happened.
But zoom out here a little bit and you see
the hilarious hypocrisy of the event.
They hold an event to talk about the supposed
suppression of conservative voices by social
media.
They invite no one that has actually being
been banned.
Uh, they suppress even center left voices,
nevermind progressive ones.
And they demand that everybody submit their
questions ahead of time, effectively putting
in place the same type of moderation that
they criticize the right won't even understand
the absurdity of this.
But this is sort of like the joke that's no
longer funny.
This is weaponized ignorance as I've been
saying, and it's inside the White House.
The White House in this case is the source
of it rather than just the place that is unable
to deal with what it is that is going on out
on social media and on the Internet.
So I, I couldn't tell you one thing that was
gained from doing this other than seeing the
just hilarious, uh, the hilariously inaccurate
way in which the White House claims to understand
or interpret what it is that's going out there
on social media.